hakeem finley's family say he's being
punished twice
for a crime he has already spent three
years in prison for
he was convicted of grievous bodily harm
in 2014
but because he only came to britain from
jamaica at the age of 10
he's facing deportation his grandparents
were from the windrush generation
there's going to be a lack of
communication we're not going to be able
to talk as much
i'm not going to know where he is i'm
not even if i wanted to go out there how
am i going to know where he is to go out
there because
there's no one so how is he going to get
a job how's he going to eat
nicole says her fiance has turned his
life around completely
and his adulting father who just wants a
second chance
i spoke to hakeem briefly by phone as he
awaited confirmation of his deportation
that my mental health is going
yeah i'm up distressed i've been put on
depression tablets
and everything like i'm i'm depressed
right now like
i'm being deprived of my family life
many of them have never even stepped
foot in jamaica since they arrived in
the uk
campaigners point out that many of those
being deported have no
family or friends still in jamaica and
some of them have mental health problems
for some it really is a death sentence
it's a death sentence
or at the very least it's
destitution and homelessness and
vulnerability to exploitation
there are people on the flight who have
no family in jamaica
who have learning severe learning
disabilities and medical conditions
that need care and they will not survive
in jamaica but in a statement the home
office said
people who come to this country and
commit crimes should be
expected to be removed that is why we
regularly operate
charter flights to different countries
to remove foreign offenders
and those who have no right to be in the
country but refused or failed to leave
voluntarily
the jamaican government has called for
this flight to be halted
over concerns about importing the delta
variant
for akeem and his family the agonizing
wait for news
goes on and the brady sky news